tell me when you're ready
yeah
all right uh welcome back um for part
two of The Polar codes uh
tutorial okay thank you for coming back
so uh last hour we kind of left off here
where we say this is how we prove that
polar code has exponential decay Gap to
capacity and and properly exponential
decaying error and then we say that by
moving the red line you can kind of
fine-tune your um your your exponent and
then if you kind of push the red line
all the way to the left you can prove
the optimal error but then you cannot
retain a very good scaling
exponent so basically you are
alternating between these two
possibilities where you either have a
very good scaling exponent or you have
very good error uh Behavior and then the
very natural question is is there any
you know middle line can can we found a
curve that kind of interpolate between
these two curve
so uh the short answer is that of course
you can you just have to um dive into it
and and study it really hard so here is
a a very um simple um representation of
what happened here so you begin with um
this one so so let's say so here is the
graph and most of the information are
irrelevant it will be relevant uh later
so the horizontal axis is the exponent
in the error so when when I say the
error is doubly exponential there is
going to be some exponent so I call it
pi and then row is the exponent in the
uh Gap to capacity so these are the uh
the two quantities that I I'm
interesting in and I'm kind of normalize
that taking log and normalize back the
block lens such that they become kind of
stable stabilizing the picture after n
goes to infinity and then what we are
interesting in is this point so this
point is
one2 this point means that the arrow
exponent is 1/2 and this point means
that the arrow exponent is about one
over
3627 so this point is the
optimal um optimal error behavior that I
showed in the previous slide and then
this point is the optimal error behavior
in site and then there's like a tradeoff
curve between these two
point
and and and and and the proof is uh the
the the this proof is in two steps so in
early work this is Meli heni and Ubank
they kind of present this result so they
present this uh this estimation the the
the that is the location of this point
and they kind of present this whole
curve by using a very simple argument
that if you go back to this curve you
tell me which way you want to be do you
want to get better error then I'll push
the red KN to this way or you want to
get better scaling exponent and then
I'll push the red line to this place so
so there is an optimal place that you
can place the red line and then by doing
that you can achieve every point on on
this curve on on the curve my my hand is
shaking so on this curve that is below
um so so you see that of course this is
a very straightfor argument and there is
nothing questionable about it um but
there is one thing that is
unsatisfactory namely if you push the
curve toward the left namely if you want
better and better error exponent you
will see that there's a gap between the
optimal error exponent and the op
optimal um optimal exponent you get if
you
want uh if if if you want the tradeoff
and then you specialize the tradeoff at
this special point so that's that is one
kind of uh open problem back then
because um it seems that there is
something that need to be done to at
least um connect these two lines so
um I kind of attacked this problem and
then I came up with a result that says
that basically says that yes you can
attain this a curve that precisely
connected to this point and then
precisely connected to uh this point and
then the special thing is that this
curve is uh it's a convex conjugate of
two things so the first thing is that
you have the optimal uh scaling exponent
and then here you have a binary entropy
function uh inverted binary entropy
function fun and then this curve sits
under the binary entropy function and
then shoots to that scaling exponent
point when it's tangent to uh to to to
the binary entropy function so that's
that's the characterization of that
curve so you can see
that maybe this Rings a bill but in in
large deviation Theory you you often see
this where if you take the convex
conjugate of a function that is not
convex and then you take the conjugate
twice it will get the the function will
be
completed like
um so is this for the BC specifically
for the BC yes yes for now let's talk
about BC whatever that thing you got yes
that that point that I cannot draw on
this but uh so that point is going to be
one over 3.62
7 and and uh and and this curve is uh
obtained by uh taking the convex
envelope uh of two things of the two
important things so I mean
philosophically this is kind of means a
lot like um the only thing you care is
the scaling exponent and then the error
Behavior because everything in between
is like completed by the theor itself do
you know that that curve is optimal for
the
BC like uh for actually I should say for
error
cons uh
uh uh yeah yeah I know your question but
uh I didn't prove it but if you're
looking to the proof it's quite optimal
yeah so
um um there might be a way to kind of
specialize U like turning all the in
yeah we we we we can we we can get into
that but the the basic idea is that um
you are no longer using one one red line
in in in the in the plot here so instead
of using one we already know that this
argument works but it doesn't work well
because you have to choose the place and
then if you choose the place you get
this suboptimal curve so what you did is
I'm going to choose a lot of red lines
I'm going to place the red line all over
the place and then I'm to talk
about um how many um how many channels
that touches the forbidden zone and how
many channel that doesn't touch the
forbidden zone so um the the upper half
is like the formal definition but the
lower half
um uh is the kind of like the idea of
what happened so imagine that um where
is the one okay so imagine that this set
is the set of all channels and then they
kind of split between those channels
that decided to go down to avoid the
forbidden zone or those channels that
decided they want to enter the void uh
the the forbidden zone and then for
those that enter the bottom of the
forbidden Zone you do the hting
inequality stop here if you do the hting
inequality stop here then have then most
of your channel will get sufficiently
many squaring through the hting process
so so you exit here because now you
become now these channels has very low z
values and then there are channels that
have very bad Z Valu so they kind of
re-enter the forbidden zone because they
fail to obtain sufficiently many
squaring and then you kind of say okay
now I I'm going to recycle this Channel
and then I'm going to check again
whether they went down to the bottom of
the forbidden zone and then they kind of
Branch again so these part of the
channels they went down to the forbidden
zone but like the second forbidden zone
not the first
one and then once they enter the second
forbidden zone you'll have another
chance to apply Hing inequality so you
apply Hing inequality again and then
there are channels that fail the Hing
inequality and you recycle again and
then you kind of repeat this process for
about root end steps and um so you can
see this is like a direct generalization
of the argument of Meli haeni and Bank
uh in the sense that their argument is
like stopping
here but then you can continue if you
kind of extend their argument in this
way and I think this is a very natural
way then you will get um a very good
behavior
um that that basically says um let's see
if I have the
slide that that basically says U you can
get the optimal scaling exponent with a
very very weak error and once you get
optimal scaling exponent with a very
weak error you apply another argument
that's basically the same but this time
you are no longer recycling channels
you're going to say
okay I'm going to apply the scaling
exponent argument here so some chance
will decide that they will go to the
bottom of the forbidden zone and then
there is a very very long process of uh
applying squaring or doubling to the
iral probability and then eventually at
almost the end of the process uh some of
the channel will have very good error
probability and then you also and then
you apply the same argument the second
time when when when the level is at two
root n and then you apply the same
argument one more time when the level is
uh three root n and so on and so forth
so um this is the basic idea in pictures
and then um uh if you kind of finish the
com fill in the combinatorial details
like how long is this segment so there
is a whole thing inequality with n
equals this quantity and
then you control the this the channels
that you lost and so on and so
forth then you will get back to um this
curve uh this uh Improvement of the old
result curve that achieve both the
optimal scaling exponent and the optimal
exponent sorry just CL you mean there is
one curve improve improving that curve
PL uh so so this is the old curve this
is like 16 result uh but this is like 18
result so this one is the new curve uh
there there's a there's a line
connecting the citation to the curve
yeah not very
obvious any other
question actually uh I I'm posibly lost
but what what what what function are you
taking the lower con V envelope on like
function do I take the
uh you mean the this this here
thing uh you draw lower com oh oh oh oh
oh okay okay yes yes uh you mean this
gray curve this this
one oh no no I mean I mean on the white
board we have draw this
one so what function are you uh so this
so this is just idea like what hap what
happened to this curve is that um there
is a so in Gray there is this function
that is a binary entropy function
inverted so this is one over H2
Z and then this point isn't really a a
curve this this part is more like
there's just only one point so so you
put you put a point here and then you
kind of say what's the convex envelope
of these two things so the convex that
you go from here it used to be infinity
and then you go from here you you turn
left and then you go for this point the
tangent point and then you go up again
and of course it doesn't really make
sense on the right hand side so so this
part means that the code becomes very
bad you you have very low probability to
to recover any information but this is
this isn't very important we're
interesting in this part so that's the
that's the curve right over
there thanks okay okay thank you
okay let's move
on so that's the argument um with
pictures and precise
definitions so
um so so you have asked several
questions like uh does it apply to BC
and then the answer is yes but
then it's a good question because those
argument applies to channels Beyond BC
so now let's look at what will happen if
you apply large gen large matrices to to
the polarizing um
circuit okay so this is what we begin
with this you have seen this multiple
time this is the uh encoding and
decoding
Contraption and you can pay certain
amount of resources to upgrade this
circuit okay so it's like a a mobile
game so let's this let's upgrade and
then you can uh so so instead of 2x two
matrices on the left hand side now you
have 3x3 matrices on the left hand side
and then this thing this whole thing
will become a little bit complicated so
so what happens is that you will get
three uh input and then you want to
guess what is this U1 based on these
three input and then there's a genie
that going to that's going to tell you
hey this is the correct U1 So based on
that U1 you guess what's the best U2 and
then you submit your guess and then the
genie will tell you hey this is the
correct U2 and then you guess you okay
so many many steps but it's okay and
then so so you have this 3x3 matrices
construction and then the next question
is that is this going to get any better
than than the original proposal by Aron
and the answer is uh sadly not
so um so there are two choices either
you stick with eron's design or you go
one step further and upgrade it
again and then you can okay you do all
the decoding and encoding definition so
you solve for U1 and then you you get
the correct U1 you sol for U2 you get
the correct U2 you sol for u3 and so on
and so forth and then these channels I
um because there are many many choice
for this a kernel these channels will
become new channels where the iraal
probability are going to be Pol nomial
in Z where Z is the channel you begin
with okay so make one of the job to
evaluate the performance of the
polinomial is to figure out what is the
correct polinomial here and once you
have the correct polinomial here you
apply the convex function
[Music]
argument and you can appli it again to
five to 7 to
eight okay so so in the previous uh
couple slides the magical bow is L by L
matrices such as this one I'm giving
here and then I'm going to uh let X1 to
XL be U1 to UL this is a row Vector
multiplied by that Matrix so for example
this a by a Matrix and then out that y1
to y l be the channel output if the
input is S1 to x r l this should be an L
um and then the J's new channel so the
J's new channel is the the the J's
channel on the right hand side will
be uh will be this channel where the
input you want to guess is UJ and the
output is y1 to y l and also the genie
will tell you U1 to u j minus one so the
all the previous uh bits the genie will
tell you the correct answer and then
based on this information based on this
I should say the definition um you can
compute F FJ of
Z by doing the following process this is
a very concise expression but the
process is as follows so you begin with
the channel and then you take you take
The Columns of the channel as if it's a
set you take any subset of that kernels
that columns and then you say I'm going
to let CJ be the first be be the Matrix
C except that the first J rows are
removed
so the picture is you begin with the
channel and then you take a subset of
columns and then you're going to remove
the first
J uh rows and also you also have to uh
construct another copy where you only
remove the first J minus one rows and
then you say if I remove one more Row
from J minus one to J does it decrease
the rank of the Matrix below and you ask
this question you kind of compute the
row redu Hong form to um to to see if
there is a pivot at the first row and
then you say if there is a pivot at the
first row you are going to you're going
to add this quantity to the final
polinomial so this quantity is a mon
monomial that remembers the size of
C so here's the recipe uh
uh that is kind of complicated but it's
a deterministic algorithm that you can
apply and once you apply you'll get all
the functions fub1 to F5 and once you
get F1 to F5 you can put them on the
heel and then
uh you can uh found the the quantity
Where you evaluate the new H values and
divided by the old H value and then you
kind of upper bound that quantity to
find if this constant the constant that
you obtain this way will be the constant
that that that correspond to the old
construction of
Aron and if it does it means that you
kind of improve Aron's result because
now you have a better uh scaling
exponent than what is used currently
okay so here is a a crash course of
history um these two work
H Alisha abank and then another work
kada monali Tata and ban they kind of
figure out that the correct value over
BC of the AR kernel is that value on the
left hand side of the Whiteboard um but
the
of course we're not interesting in the
precise value so I'm just represent them
by two points and then in 2014 it's like
couple years after polar Cod I invented
we finally finally found a kernel that
is better than aran's
kernel so this is kind of significant so
first of all there is an improvement to
be made right we we don't know we don't
know there's an improvement before this
result so they kind of show that okay
there there's an improvement and so of
course if you can do 8 by 8 people will
do what about 12 x 12 what about 16 by
16 so that part is Trivial the the
really nontrivial part is that there
isn't any channel between 2 by two and 8
by8 that outperform Aron
construction so you think about that
this is like this is like a magic
because it's not that Aron's kernel is
optimal it's Sally strong but still
beatable in
way okay so that's what happens in 2014
and then um uh in the following years
people have been working on larger
kernel 66 242 3222 and then the largest
possible kernel is 644 uh Yao is
currently in the audience uh he showed
that this thing how the scaling exponent
here is one over
2.87 sorry right here so this one
this
seven um and I don't remember the
numbers in between but some something
like 3.5 and 3.2 around here and then
finally sub three here so um this one is
also a very interesting result um in two
ways the first reason this is
interesting is that polar code is the
only code we can prove that there's a
finite scaling
exponent so in a way this kernel is
like the the best kernel we do the best
explicit construction we know when it
comes to constructing
code okay the second reason this is
interesting is that if you go to the
work of some uh ldpc or especially
specially couple ldpc code there's a
heris argument that says that um if
everything goes well then specially
couple ldpc code will have scaling
exponent three so it means that I
shouldn't write this down but don't
quote me on this ldpc is about one
over3 and this one over 2.8 is better
than one
over3
so even if you consider even if you take
into account that oh I I maybe I should
accept this theistic argument because uh
physics are always right this kernel is
still better
okay so so let this is the story about
64 by 64 um what about the the thing in
between like there is this uh weird line
in between uh this is a work where we
try to use not large matrices but we try
to use 2 by two Matrix over
F4 to achieve the same thing that other
people have been chasing around
so what's that well let's go back to our
favorite picture this is the con
construction that aricon came out with
and then we upgraded except that we're
upgrading it in a different direction so
this time we upgrading it by putting two
bits here so now the line becomes double
line and then this double line after
multiplying this 2 x two Matrix over
gf4 the first component goes into
a pair of binary eraser channels and the
second component goes into another pair
of binary eraser channels and then they
go to an output processor that takes
this is two bit which is the F4 element
and then there's another F4 element so
this output device takes a pair of f4
elements and then it output the first
guest of the first F4 elements and then
there's a genie that tells you the
correct value is this qu this particular
value and then this device will compute
the second um gas of the uh the second
F4
element and by doing that you can uh you
can uh construct two new channels whose
input whose input alphabet is of size
four okay so you start with the binary
ra Channel but then you work on um quary
channels so what is interesting about uh
this work is that okay first of all you
don't have to stay with F4 you can
always go higher you can go f8 F16 F32
and um if you do the simulation you'll
find that the larger the alphabet get
the better performance they are but
there is a ceiling there's a invisible
ceiling that's some somewhere between um
2.5 this 2.5 is with the quotation like
this is a simulation result we don't
have a proof but if you go for a very
large alphabet this is what you will get
okay so compare this quantity with other
quantity we'll see that this one has the
potential to kind of like beat the
previous
works okay so that's the first
thing the open problem is that can you
prove this rigorously can you prove that
so I mean isn't this weird because it's
not one half
the the simulation clearly shows that
the optimal value is not one half so the
problem is why is this why this
particular value and then the other
problem is can you get to this value
with some mathematically rigorous
proof and the second the second thing
that I I want to comment about is that
usually when we think about alphabet
extension by alphabet and by alphabet
extension I mean you work the the
channel you want to Comm communicate
over is a binary eraser Channel but then
you work when you do the encoding and
decoding you work on a larger alphabet
so this is alphabat extension and
usually when you do alphabat extension
there is this uh pattern design pattern
where you go for a inner code and then
you use that inner code to kind of
process your information such that
outside this inner code it looks like a
eraser Channel with a very large queue
and then with this eraser Channel with
very large L quue you kind of apply a
reolon code that works on a very large
queue so that's the design pattern for
alab extension and uh the the the more
precise term is concatenation code
concatenation but what happened here is
different because we are directly
applying our large alphabet mechanism to
the binary usure channel so there is no
middle ground there's this is bare metal
this is like I I'm going to take that as
a very large alphabet Channel and then
I'm going to directly work on that and
and so so first of all this is not what
people usually do and second thing is
that why does it work well it works
because polar code never lose any
capacity the sum of the capacity is
always constant okay so we can't afford
doing things that traditional coding uh
the didn't
[Music]
do okay
my yeah I think I'm maybe this notation
like the EC of Z all Cub does this mean
like you know if one of the bits gets
deleted I still I guess I still have
some partial information about what the
Sy what the like element of f8 is
and ah sorry sorry this this notation
just means
this sure yeah yeah okay so so yeah so
if you so you if you if you say one
symbol like this is one this three bits
then this one get delete you can kind of
see the projection onto this Subspace
yes it's like you know magic one that
actually exploit that fact or yes yes it
will like
um it basically takes because the the
input is like f8 in this case it's
f8 two yeah right and then you you want
to
Output uh a have two
def actually you want to Output R8 so
this is the two of posterior
probabilities of every symbol sure yeah
yeah so maybe another say it is that you
take this channel which acts on three
bits or or two bits if you do the thing
and think of it as a channel which acts
on
F4 and then do all the machinary I see
so it's it's not an your your channel
anymore it's something it's some
complicated Channel complicated I still
polarize it yeah okay I get it yeah we
we get that so so first of all we get
the guarantee that um I think is Sag
prove that polar code works for arbitary
alphabet so first of all this will
definitely work okay the question is
whether or not this is better than the
pre than if there is only one channel
every line so yeah so first of all we
know it works we just have to prove that
it's better and then in order to prove
that better we have to exploit the fact
that there is BC it is a product for BC
so if this is a product of BC the output
will not will not be arbitrary arbitrary
large alphabet Channel it will be large
alphabet Channel but the the the the
arrrow is some type of eraser pattern
there is still there is still eraser
patterns in it it's not so it's not
arbitrary real numbers it's like you can
you can use uh uh so one over one over
two one over four and one
over8 and if it's one over8 then the 1
over8 is distributed in the
Subspace there's a so there's a special
structure to be explode and um so here's
an interesting graph that I draw
question yes can you elaborate a little
more on what are the simulations that
you said that lead to the mean this one
ah
uh uh uh let's
see so you draw a very big circuit
okay so there's some line um so you draw
a very big circuit but it's finite and
um you got these
channels and we got like complete
description of the channels we are not
simulating the input we can characterize
the the channels in hold so so these
channels we put them on a concave
curve and
see what's the summ menion of H of these
channels and so this so so there's going
to be a plot where uh the horizontal
line is n and then this is like log of
the sum of H and then you kind of fit
that with the best straight line you can
have but then there's no randomization
in the structure there's no random no
there's no randomization there is one
only one thing that you need to
determine namely this beginning Z so you
fix Z equals 1/2 because that's a very
fair value and once that has done these
channels are
determin and so so this is like a fixed
quantity and then this is like fixed
quantity and then you you can do the uh
what's
that a square or something you want
yeah okay no question okay so so this is
a very interesting picture that I that I
drew to to express the idea so um you
see the the very big rectangle is the
discrete M Channel which is like the
arbitrary Channel where the input
alphabet is arbitrary and then there is
this uh
uh leave thing which says binary memory
symmetric channels and then on the side
of the binary memory symmetric Channel
there is uh binary eraser channels so
this is what we used to this is what we
have been discussing about but
now the work with large alphabet what do
we do here is
that inside this discrete memory the
channel class there is a quinary
channels which means that Channels with
input alphabet four and then inside this
we have this special tetrahedral eral
channels which says that which relates
to to your question that we are indeed
using the special structure of the
output we are not considering arbitrary
quinary channels we're considering this
special structure and then inside this
special structure we Define two new
classes of channels Ed heavy tecs and
balance tecs and then we prove our
scaling exponent in this
area Okay so so so the trick to proving
scaling exponent is that if you have to
optimize your function in the very large
space it's not going to be a very good
uh scaling exponent so the the fewer you
can limit the channels the better
exponent you can
[Music]
prove okay so so that's that's that's
what I want to say about larger matrices
and then we can uh uh we can move move
on to large alphabet um but before we
can move on to large alphabet we move on
to Binary memories Channel which is like
the binary version of a complicated
challenge okay so again we start with
this uh diagram and uh we kind of we are
not upgrading this diagram in know we
are kind of downgrading it so we go for
the hard mode which is that um now the
binary eraser Channel becomes binary
symmetric channels and then the output
channel will will be um W minus and w+
so this is just the notation for the
channel um in general these channels are
nontrivial so so the the bad one is
still going to be a binary symmetric
channels but the good one is going to be
some channels that live in the larger
space um and so if you kind of reapply
reiterate this constrution with many
many layers of uh of uh magical devices
then the channels will become highly
highly non-trivial they are no longer
eraser Channel they are no longer vscs
they're just arbitrary generic binary
channels that looks like awgn which is a
good thing because we are familiar with
awgn but they are not exactly adfg so
that's the B
part okay so these two channels are not
simple channels so they are not simple
channels means that you have to invent
new inequalities of the form where you
try to express the you try to find the
function first of all you find a
function that can evaluate your channel
to a real number and then you say say oh
I'm going to choose bachia parameter
because Aran choose bachara parameter
and then I'm going to say the Bacher
parameter of the good channel is going
to be Z Square where Z is the Bacha
parameter of the old Channel and for the
bad Channel Z of the bad channel is
going to be in this weird interval it
used to be that there is an equality
sign here but now 2 Z minus z s is just
an upper bound and then there's a lower
bound okay
so so so it becomes a different problem
when it comes to Upper bounding this quo
because now you look at this quo uh the
denominator is 2 h of Z and the
numerator one of it this one is going to
be h of Z squ which is what we had uh in
the past now this one is H of something
that lives between 2 Z minus z s and Z *
< tk2 minus z
s okay so now you are optimizing this
quoti by finding a function that uh
minimize the supremum of this quotient
over a space where the the argument on
the right hand side is in an
interval okay so that's the difficult
part and uh so so although it's it's
it's kind of quite complicated but
people still manage to do that because
in the end you just apply power method
and then when you implement the power
method you kind of like make some very
careful choice you kind of you want to
simulate where is the uh where where
should this where should this particular
value B and then you can prove these
results so so you want to so you want to
bound the scaling exponent over binary
symmetric channels and the first result
is by gu Swami and sha who proves that
there is a positive scaling exponent
there's an implicit number but it's a
positive scaling exponent so it's not
obvious here but um if you kind of zoom
in you will see that uh it didn't go all
the way to the end there's a positive
Improvement and then uh people come
after and see uh what they can do so
maybe some people are proving upper
bound and some people are improving
lower bound and um so this all happens
around uh 2010s and then in 2022 we made
an improvement that doesn't look like an
improvement because it's almost
identical but there is like a zero 0.7%
Improvement in the lower
bound um after like eight years of the
previous work uh eight years after the
previous B bound so what happened
there
well the the last one is interesting
because we bound something different
than the quotient we bound this uh
twostep
quotient uh uh instead of the one step
quo so so think about that what what
what what does this quo mean this quo is
in fact the square of this
quotient if every CH if there are some
channels
that if all the channels attain the
supremum of this
quo then this will be the square of
that but what the but the reality is
that not all channels not all Z's will
attain the supremum of this function
because remember there's a uh there's a
interval in this argument so
not not all channel will attain the
supremum of this quion means that if we
consider two-step quo there's going to
be a mismatch and then we can get a
lower bound so the situation is like if
you have a if you have a matrix using a
discrete analog if you have a matrix and
then V is its
ion what's that ion Vector then a square
V is going to be
uh Lambda Square
V
but if but if V is not an IG
Vector then it's going to be smaller
than Lambda Square V so what we prove is
that we prove that it is not possible to
find an IG
Vector there is not a an i vector and if
you if you can show that by doing some
heavy duty uh numerical computation then
you can then you can improve the scaling
exponent but even if you do that you can
you can only say that there is some
improvement can be made to the scaling
exponent so we kind of make it we make
the computation more precise and we are
able to get a
concrete um
Improvement concrete numerical
improvement from 1 over
4.76
to 1 over
4.95 is the
0.7% uh improve
movement okay so that's the binary
symmetric Channel case um which is
already hard but it can get even harder
mean the other way around you improve
from more 4.95
4 no the number is wrong the there is a
the
six
uh yeah okay so so this is a binary uh
symmetric Channel case which is also all
the BMS Channel and we can go even
harder we can consider discret
memoryless channel so it's like now we
are getting all the rectangle we're
considering all the channels that
Shannon has considered in his Innovation
paper in
1948 okay so in this case we still still
have the same uh problem that w+ and W
minus are not simple channels and then
we have a another bad news which is that
the the bachara parameter doesn't work
anymore so you have to invent
inequalities of the form where you're
trying to compute the entropy of the bad
channels and then entropy of the good
Channel and then we want to lower bound
this quantity for all channels for all
channels let me emphasize there is an
infinite amount of channels living in a
space that is very abstract we don't
quite know if the space is equipped with
topology or matrix it's just some set
unstructured set and then we want to
prove in this inequality how is that
even possible but um but but but it is
provable because um um I mean this has
been done before sasagu proved
that polio can work over arbitrary
alphabet if you
use complicated enough kernel
but then there is this open problem like
can you optimize this whole thing like
we optimized the binary eras channel
right can we optimize this inequality
can we find another parameter maybe H is
not the best parameter we can use maybe
there are some parameters also not B
parameter maybe a total
variation parameter or something else we
don't know but so this this is the open
problem
okay so um it's a it's a very difficult
question and um so the next thing people
do is that what if we combine these two
ideas so on the left hand side we have
large matrices which will improve the
behavior of polar code and then on the
right hand side we have things that will
make uh the scaling exponent worse so
what what do we combine these two we get
that the the optimal Gap the optimal Gap
to capacity is one over
square root of the block L over discret
discret memory this is proven by I think
it began with ston and then all the way
there are many people working on this
and then the latest guy is
pooni um trying to find better and
better bound and better and better um
constant so there's a constant here it's
not one there's a constant that depends
on the details of the channel but um in
general I'll just say it's one over root
block length
so on the Polar C side so those are
people who work on random on the Polar
call that we have in 2019 p and Ubank
proves that if you consider q erasor
channel then you can express the scaling
exponent in terms of
Q and then if you let Q goes to Infinity
this scaling exponent will converge to
the optimal value over here so I'm
putting this dot here and then in 2021
fazeli hen Meli and
V proved that you don't have to let Q
goes to Infinity the BC will
work okay and the way the becc work is
they try to they try to find a large
random Matrix and then they find all uh
so let's see do we have space for large
M so so they find the very large Matrix
and then they do the whole thing where
let's just say let's sample a subset of
columns and then let's delete the first
J roles and then whether or not this row
has a pivot will give us a polinomial
that looks like this so if if the large
kernel is the random kernel then this
function is kind of like a random
variable that depends on the choice of
the kernel right so now it's getting
more and more complicated and the
Notions are nested but but okay so you
have this function that are random
variables that you can control its
coefficient
uh when you use the basis Z to the
certain power one minus Z to the certain
power so this is also called the burn
side basis so you use a bir side basis
to express the function you control the
coefficient the coefficient uh is going
to be because this is a random kernel
you kind of enumerate all invertible
matrices so so the coefficient is going
to be related to the number of subspaces
and the number of subspaces intersecting
each other so there are some Q binomial
coefficient stuff there and then they
Pro very strong inequality to show that
the scaling exponent is
two okay so now we're getting really
excited because we can prove the best
scaling exponent uh over uh binary eral
channel so then uh people come in and uh
prove that if you kind of extend that
argument to Binary symmetric Channel you
can also prove the best scaling exponent
and then you can even extend that to
discrete memory list channel so so so at
this point the story kind of like
complete because this is the channel
this is the channel That channel has
considered in his uh uh seminal paper
and then we kind of proved that polar
code achieved the best possible Skilling
exponent over all the channels that uh
that the founding father has the beat
player has considered but of course
there are not there are more channels
but like this is like a historical uh
miles
milestone
okay so
see very good so here is a a picture of
um of a table and I will review the
content of the table so the table start
with the column that has problemy Theory
code random coding Theory and then po
coding Theory as its rols and then the
first thing I want to address is that
there is an analog of law of large
numbers namely any channel has a capacit
okay the notion of capacity stem from
the fact that there's an oper bound on
how good you can do and then there's a
lower bound there's a construction that
shows you can indeed do that so there is
a capacity the capacity is a number that
works like the mean in probability
Theory and poal Achieve capacity which
is proved by a console okay good so now
we kind of complete uh the First Column
the next column is Central limit theorem
which says that if you take the sum of
IID random variables and then you
rescale properly and by properly I mean
divided by root n where N is a number of
samples then you get a cauan
distribution and the analog to this is
that in random coding Theory you the the
the optimal Gap to capacity you can get
is also about one / root 10 and of
course there is some Works focusing on
what is the correct constant instead of
one and then after you find the the
precise constant there is like what's
the lower term is the lower term log n
is the lower term uh one/
n and there are Works working on that
and and the lower term will depends on
the structure of
the uh of the
channel and we just said and we just
seen in the previous slide that for
Polar coding you can achieve Capal
capacity that is almost optimal so fix
any constant Epsilon I can achieve Gap
to cap it 1 - n to the 12 minus Epsilon
power okay so now we finish the second
column um there is a another column that
says large
deviations and um so large deviation is
like hold thing inequalities but there
are other inequalities um large
deviations correspond to in random
coding the the error exponent so the so
the error exponent is a positive
exponent what does it build on it build
on the fact that the error is almost
always exponential decay in n and then
we in polar code we can achieve similar
thing we we can achieve exponential
decay in N except that we have to put a
little sacrifice here on the shoulder of
n okay it's funny
but this is what we can do and you can
actually you can prove that if you use a
fixed kernel this is the best thing you
can
do so there is always in epsilon and of
course you have to ask the question like
what's the dependency on Epsilon because
otherwise I'm just
cheating but those are for future works
so and then we also uh talk about
moderate deviation so the moderate
deviation is like what's the trade off
between scaling exponent Behavior and
the large deviation behavior and then
there's like a convex function between
them so here is the correct
up to minor term description of what
random code can achieve and what polar
code and Achieve and you can see that so
in this uh in this expression e is the
error G is the gap to capacity so the
error is is double exponential so you
take two logs and and G you take only
one log and then there's like there's a
conservation law that says that um your
block length is like your income and you
can use your block length to buy good
eror probability or buy good Gap to
capacity but there is some uh conversion
rate you can only buy this much and for
Poco we can do pretty much very
impressively same result except that
there is some fee that we need to pay
okay and by paying this fee polar code a
achieve this behavior of random code and
also analog to the uh problem
probability Theory Behavior with
encoding and decoding complexity and log
n where n is the block lens so this is
very good because because think about
that what what what does the Polar code
mean we're not interested in using polar
code in real life we use red sorry
whatever what what does random code mean
we're not interested in using random
code in real life we're interested in
like proving upper bound and lower Bond
and polical come in and say yeah your Lo
B actually are achievable using a very
straightforward uh encoder and CER
so kind of we're talking about solving
problems okay so
um I I I guess I will stop here so I I
hope you are happy and then I I have a
final remark that U why do I put this
picture here and and then only talk
about the top two and and these things
because I want to I want you to
understand that these are very
interesting branches of polar code and
um so basically every problem here
multiple asset Channel broadcast where
typ Channel you can check if this table
holds like do you achieve Gap to
capacity but then what what's the
capacity well there's going to be a
capacity region if you talk about
multiple asset Channel or distributed uh
compression so so you you kind of like
you have to change the uh the definition
a little bit but then you can also check
if they can achieve the best behavior um
for these problems and these problems
and then the these problems are harder
like insertion Edition channel are
harder classical Comm channel are harder
so for this channel for example we don't
know what's their scaling exponent
Behavior Uh for this one I think it's
the same and then there is like coded
computation which is not quite
communication but still you can use
polar code to protect your computation
of Matrix Vector multiplication and then
there's this thing pack decoder and list
decoding which we don't even know if it
achieve capacity theoretically of course
if we do the simulation it is very good
but um but the the the interesting part
is that you prove things because science
is about discovering the same thing
using different P so already know we
already know that the simulation will
work so now the problem the open problem
is that whether or not we can
prove to some extent that the list
decoder is good or it is superior to a
decoder with the list so I'll stop here
and thank you very much for
attending thank you very much uh any
questions on the last Point
uh so basically what one question is
does it improve the scaling exponent is
there do you
know any results that really I don't
know one the other I don't know I I
because it
generalize old code so we have the same
exponent but other than that just like
er's code with
coding with this actually that's there
is a subtle point so um you can imagine
successive cancellation decoder as a
tree decoder So eventually you have a
binary tree where
so the this is what the decoder see the
decoder will see two passes and then
they will see 60% here 40% here and then
there's like more probab more
probabilities and eventually you want to
choose a point so this is what the
specific cancellation decoder do but the
successive cancellation list decoder
will kind of so it will pick maybe this
point and this point so it will maintain
these two point in the memory and then
he will compute whether or not these
four point are are good and then it will
select the first two so there is a
chance very small but there is a chance
that the decoder the list decoder will
choose this one so starting from this
point the list decoder will deviate from
the normal behavior of successive
cancellation decoder so you cannot
assume the old
analysis and things just blow up because
we don't know like you are you are
sorting these real numbers and that's
not a good thing sorting real numbers
it's very hard to control so the answer
is the the short answer is it's probably
definitely better than SC but we don't
know we cannot
prove yeah I thought there were some
papers claiming that it doesn't improve
it but I don't know
how the exact nature of those claims
because even these limitations on
scaling exponent often are only
limitations on the IG function right
it's just limitation on the analysis not
the truth so I don't know yeah there is
one my monkey that but it has a strong
restriction I think maybe that's the one
I'm referring to finite list size like
does list size to improve the exponent I
think the answer is no
okay but like this list size log log n
could you know
could that's good I guess we kind of
started the boot camp with list decoding
so I guess we
can end it there any other questions
No One
Price not of course we're not done yet
you know uh have your lunch and be back
we have H second round of speed talks
and uh then
happy